Mother's Day is approaching and the
channel wants to pay homage to those women
who work hard to support
their families, each one with their own style, each
one in a different way, but in the end with
the heart of a mother who gives
everything for her  Children, come with me to learn
the story of Viridiana Vidal
below.
My name is Vivián Navidad. For me, being a
mother has been something very special because
when I was 21 years old they told me that
I could not have children. I have
Siam endometriosis, I have it
in stage 4 and then  I had a lot of
problems when I got pregnant at
24 for me it's a surprise because it
's like they told me no and now it
turns out that if
twelve years passed I could never get
pregnant I tried everything I could
never get pregnant again and I kind of
said  Well, I already have one, they told me
that I couldn't have more children, so it's
perfect, not a year ago, because I got
pregnant again
with an even worse condition because I
had  An ovary has already been removed, they had already
told me that if you're already very, very bad it's going
to be very difficult and I had scheduled a
hysterectomy for January and I found out
that she was pregnant in October
so it was like, as they say in
English, don't lie and  that carles was born
because I thought that being a mother was not going to
make it normal for me, not
only has it been a blessing for everyone,
but for me it has
literally been a blessing because
doctors had told me that I was not going to be
able to have  children, so I always
always tell them, that is, don't give
up if they tell you that you can't because you
never know, that is, God's timing
is perfect and I believe that he will
send it to you when he has to command and be a
mother for me.
The most beautiful thing that has happened to me, having
children has been the engine that has
driven me to have a career, to have my
own business, to help other people
to have projects that I never thought I
could have, and everything is because of them, I think.
that I try to have a very
open relationship with my daughters I
try to be the cool mom but
I always remember that before her friend I am her
mother I think that today's moms are
super multitasking and we do many things
at the same time sometimes we are doing
food with a baby in hand and on the
phone solving something for a
client or working on a story
I think one of the challenges is people
judge that they don't really know the
sacrifices one makes as a mother and how
much effort  What do you do to
share not the quantity but the quality of
time with your children?
The other is that sometimes it is mentally
very tiring because you are not only
thinking about what you are doing at
work but also at the same time
you are thinking about what we are going to eat today.
There are dirty dishes my room is a
dump in the baby I need to go and
buy ours something for the baby
I don't have food anymore so
while you are focused on work
that a job in itself can be
quite tiring and stressful you have to
be you can't leave the other
obligations you have I wake up I
have to get up very early because I
work on the east coast
I go out for a run like calls well
come back and start  to think that we are all going to have
breakfast at home because there are
five of us and we are starting and while we are
thinking about what we are going to have breakfast for some
time, she answers the emails that's when
the baby wakes up the baby wants to eat
I'm still breastfeeding her so it's not
like that  I can feed her, she said
that I have to lay down the law to eat the
baby, breastfeed her and then go to the process
of what else she wants to eat apart from
milk
and then you can give the
baby breakfast to the 13 17 people
and we  No, we're going to have breakfast,
sit down, try to work for a while, but
then it's time for the
baby's nap and it's time to take her up to
sleep for a while, I spend those two hours
when she's  sleeping to work as
much as I can work
work wake up feed him
again and in the middle of that well if there are
dirty dishes wash them if I leave a
dump because the toys are
everywhere pick them up around
three in the afternoon take her out for a walk  so
that she gets bored for a while and it's time
for my 13-year-old daughter to finish
school and that is if she has homework questions
if she needs to eat again having to
think about food and then continue
working on what she does homework I
I work and at the same time we are
cooking around 7 at night more or
less and the baby starts
to want to rest so it's
bathing him, putting him to sleep, giving him milk for dinner
and trying to keep him there,
but if it's one day, one thing after  other
then I think my message is that don't
get carried away by people who
judge you for trying to do more because if
you think you can do it you can do
it you are not neglecting your children because
whatever you are  doing today is the mark
you are leaving so that your daughters
can do more tomorrow reported for the
nose nao in spanish
natalia lanzelotti